dans le portant fièrement commandes
un message de respect
un visage la solidarité visage de change
tout ce qu en train tous contre la trop
vite
vous venez de voir un extrait d'une
nouvelle campagne publicitaire du
gouvernement du québec qui a été
dévoilée aujourd'hui elle s'adresse
d'abord aux jeunes son but les inciter à
porter de masque et à respecter la
distance de 2 m dans les rassemblements
pour dire que les cas de contamination à
la coved 19 chez les jeunes adultes qui
est bête 20 à 39 ans les cas de
contamination sont en augmentation
partout au canada
est ce que le message de prévention va
atteindre sa cible j'en discute avec
arnaud granata il est président
d'infopresse monsieur canada bonsoir
bonsoir
commençons par le contenu de la
publicité qui présente le port du masque
comme étant un geste cool altruiste
responsable est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est une bonne façon de présenter les
choses pour atteindre la cible mais je
pense que oui déjà atteint la cible
parce qu'on n'essaye pas de on le dit on
entend les mots compassion humaniser
donner l'exemple donc on essaie le plus
possible de parler aux jeunes et je
trouve qu'on arrive assez bien le faire
au niveau du contenu est aussi avec ce
porte parole la route qui est une star
il est du public jeune et je crois que
c'est important aussi le message mais la
personne qui va passer ce message
et dans ce cas là je crois que c'est
assez bien assez bien réussi à parler
nous justement de l'utilisation de gens
avec la notoriété
on se rappelle ou début de la pandémie
c'est bernard de rome et dominique
michel en parler aux plus âgés là c'est
lahoud est évidemment les publics sont
totalement différents mais quelle est
l'importance d'avoir une personnalité
pour porter le message
mais que ce soit bernard de rome où l'un
d'eux même si ces deux personnalités
diamétralement opposées ce sont des gens
que le public aime ou en tout cas une
tranche de la population et dans le cas
de l'inde particulièrement ce sont des
jeunes donc y vont être plus enclins à
l'écouté plus enclins aussi à imiter son
geste dont quand il dit portaient le
masque c'est cool mais c'est sûr que par
transposition on va imaginer que les
jeunes vont vouloir eux aussi le porter
parce que c'est cool et et parce qu'ils
vont finir par donner l'exemple
on nous dit mme puis là on n'a pas trop
de détails là mais on nous dit donc que
ces publicités la été monté par cossette
qui a reçu quand même un gros contrat du
gouvernement
on eût dit que ça va être diffusé à la
télévision
c'est super un sur youtube du
gouvernement sur twitter de du
gouvernement aussi mais le message est
aussi important que ben quand je me suis
je me trompe que le canal qu'on utilise
pour atteindre les jeunes
si ça passe à la télé à la radio est-ce
qu on atteint vraiment être c où le
public cible mais si ça passe uniquement
à la télé à la radio
non parce que on le sait les jeunes sont
énormément aussi sur les médias sociaux
en même temps jeunes et un grand grand
segment de la population encore faut-il
un peu le le définir mais évidemment
c'est une publicité qui doit qui doit
être diffusée sur les médias sociaux qui
a ce qui pourrait enfin qui peut devenir
viral parce que parce que la ruda et un
influenceur sûr aussi dans les sur les
médias sociaux
donc oui il faut que ce soit diffusé
absolument sur les médias sociaux pour
que cela atteigne sa cible absolument y
les médias sociaux le sort faire de la
publicité mais moi je suis un homme
d'une autre génération
c'est quoi les médias sociaux qui
rejoignent les jeunes en ce moment mais
facebook alors on dit que les gens qui
consomment facebook c'est une population
plus vieillissante mais on peut penser à
tik tok instagram qui est une plateforme
super populaire aussi auprès auprès des
jeunes auprès des adolescents donc c'est
des gens de plateforme youtube aussi
évidemment c'est le genre de plateforme
qui va et qui doit mon avis être utilisé
pour pour faire passer ce message et je
trouve que ce qui est intéressant aussi
c'est qu'on a utilisé une forme
graphique qui est très proche de celle
du vidéoclip donc encore une fois l'idée
c'est de qu'on a un site les jeunes à
partager massivement et en ayant parlé
aussi entre eux deux sets de cette
campagne sur le masque il ya différentes
émotions pour passer le message ou
différents messages pour atteindre sa
cible
ici on parle de responsabilisation mais
certaines ont mis sur la peur d'une
scène d'animation dans leurs publicités
notamment en espagne on va vous montrer
un extrait vous allez entendre l'extrait
de cette publicité qui présentait en
espagne où justement on mise peut-être
moi je dis la peur à vous de juger voici
donc cette extrême
login obama
[Musique]
alors on comprend c'est une fête le
virus se propage dans des rassemblements
ne respectent pas les deux mètres de
distance
on se retrouve à l'hôpital sous
respirateur ici au québec le
gouvernement aussi avait publié la
semaine dernière une publicité un peu
plus certains ont dit lugubre walking
dead un peu entre guillemets c'est à
dire où les rues sont vides les gens
sont confinés chez eux puis ça dit on ne
peut pas revenir à sa misé sur la peur
dans ce genre de circonstances selon
vous est-ce que c'est gagnant où ils
font plus miser sur la responsabilité la
responsabilisation
ça peut fonctionner miser sur la peur je
pense que c'est une des stratégies de
communication particulièrement dans un
enjeu de société après je pense que
quand on veut parler à d un public qui
est plus jeune
la responsabilisation je crois va mieux
fonctionner le célibat ce faire la leçon
répare des plus vieux mais ça et
d'ailleurs
moi j'ai quand même l'impression que
dans cette publicité qu'on a vu que vous
venez de montrer on sent un brin le la
morale c'est très moralisateur en
arrière et je crois qu'on peut aussi se
détacher voir ça plutôt comme un film
comme de l'exagération et on le sait le
public jeune se sent moins moins
vulnérables a l'impression que cela que
vite va avoir un impact moins grand sur
leur santé donc forcément je pense que
ça peut créer une distance aussi ce
genre de messages très intéressant
arnaud garreta merci beaucoup et bonne
fin de semaine à vous merci à vous